bring in peter king nbcsports.com
football morning in america must read
for every football fan
oh you thought you were going to yell at
me didn't you peter
i thought we were going to brawl this
morning dan
but you do understand i don't i don't
know if john fasenda was ever considered
for the pete roselle award i know there
was a lawsuit that was going on between
fasenda's family and maybe nfl films or
the nfl but
i was just thinking contributions to the
game has fascenda's name ever come up
with those voting dan the pete rozelle
award
is not something that the selectors for
the pro football hall of fame
have anything to do with we don't vote
on it we don't
i mean i suppose if i felt strongly
about somebody i could write a letter
but
so could a coach or a
you know anybody could write a letter
but we don't pick those
and so uh i think i'm trying to
i think those are picked by by the hall
of fame
you know like by david baker and oh okay
but i'm not
i'm not positive i don't know how it
gets picked but
but really every year that they mostly
mostly try to pick somebody either for
sort of a lifetime achievement award
like
they picked dick eversol a couple of
years ago um
or for like somebody who's doing
something really good
currently they picked andrea cramer for
her
long career and also uh for the fact
that
she and hannah storm became the first uh
you know all-woman team to do games and
so
but but again i don't know exactly how
it happens
but i think john fasenda is a great
candidate
for that award because he's
his voice is the most recognizable voice
in the history of the nfl honestly yeah
that's why i thought you know i
i i kept railing for years and look i
know it's a
thankless job voting for the hall of
fame because you know no matter what you
do
somebody's going to be upset with you
but the sables i wanted to make sure
they got in with their contributions to
the sport
uh the titan steelers game is
rescheduled for later on this season
two more positive tests in tennessee why
do you think the nfl
pulled the cord on this one uh this
early
well i mean it's not that early you know
it's thursday
and i think they knew that i think what
they really wanted to do was play the
game late monday afternoon
because this is probably not the only
game that's gonna have to
get adjusted this year it's just i
thought it was a miracle that each of
the first two weeks
that 2460 tests for players
uh none of them ever came up positive
and then there was one in week three
the atlantic uh corner aj terrell
um and and then week four
obviously uh the the the
titans have broken out but i i believe i
mean i talked to
um alan dr alan sills the nfl's chief
medical officer tuesday night late
and i believed that if uh
there was there were either none or
maybe
one more positive test that they were
going to play the game this weekend
but the fact is there's no guarantee
that in the next couple of days there
won't be even a couple of more
players test positive because the
incubation period
so i think it's quite i think it's a
prudent decision now especially
after the extra test came or the uh
additional player tested positive today
um and so i think it's a smart move the
nfl
can't be putting players out uh you know
not that not that they couldn't have
played a game
with the existing roster of the
tennessee titans
but it just isn't prudent to risk
having guys out there who could be uh
incubating
and could have cove i was wondering on
the heels of this with what happened
with the raiders where they went to a
charity function
and you know you have your starting
tight end you're starting quarterback
there
uh and they don't have mask on at least
for a portion of this
fundraiser there you've already had the
franchise find 250 000
john gruden one fined thousand dollars
the nfl going to come down
on the raiders they should uh the nfl
should come down on the raiders
um that was an incredibly tone-deaf
thing that the raiders did
and uh you know look
without getting too political the
problem in our country right now dan
is that everybody is getting mixed
messages
uh about uh the efficacy of wearing
masks
and unfortunately it's absolutely
without
any question that wearing mat wearing a
mask
will help prevent the spread of covid19
and to be out in public
when all through the course of your
training camp
and the first three weeks of the season
it's mass mass mass mass mass
and then you go out in public yeah where
theoretically
everybody isn't wearing mess like they
are inside a football facility
and your and the players are not wearing
masks
i just i i was shocked to see that
really and
i don't know who should get penalized
whether it's the players or whether it's
the franchise but the nfl's got to do
something about that
and then i wonder you know once we heard
about the titans and the vikings and
then if the titans were going to be able
to play
uh you know can you punish an
organization if they
have positives you know i don't know how
you dole out blame in a situation like
this pete
do you take away a draft pick uh is it
just going to be finding an organization
like with the raiders does the nfl have
any kind of blueprint of how they're
disciplining or will disciplined teams
well i mean i think it's
a pretty sticky situation if a team
tests positive and you have to postpone
a game
it strikes me as a little bit draconian
to then take a draft choice away from a
team because
a coach or a player or players or
coaches
uh get coven i no no i don't i don't
i don't really think that's the way to
go i i just don't
but if you're out in public i
definitely think it's the way to go and
if you could find out that
any of the titans uh if you could prove
or
whatever that they're out at some
nightclub or even an indoor restaurant
or whatever
without a mask on that's when you have
to penalize them but
without knowing where this came from or
how it came
i i would not think that the nfl should
uh should penalize a team he's peter
king nbc sports his column football
morning
in america if you ran the jets
what would you do um
i'd probably give adam gays maybe three
more weeks
but if the games are not
very competitive uh and if the
quarterback continues to be as
inconsistent as he is
uh even though look the quarterback
doesn't have a lot of help right now
he's had a lot of injuries at receiver
and and running back but i
i would not hesitate midway through the
season to pull the plug and go to greg
williams
i mean he was five and three as an
interim coach sort of damning with faint
praise but man that greg williams is one
heck of an interim coach
you know i mean so uh i
but it's you don't wanna
you don't wanna be unfair to adam gase
especially in a season that
is a lost cause but i'd find it pretty
hard to believe that adam gase can
save himself uh and and look
your players don't want to go out and
feel like
hopeless helpless every week and
uh i think they have had a couple of
really bad
performances the last couple of weeks
can a team
hire an assistant from another team
during the season
to be the head coach if the jets fired
adam gase and they said to eric the
enemy
we want to hire you that's a really good
question i never thought of that
i probably should have thought of that
but i don't think they can
dan i don't think the nfl would allow it
um
you know particularly because and look
you mentioned b enemy obviously he's
he's a black man but uh
you think in most cases that
you want to have a fair and open process
to hire a coach
i don't think the nfl would allow it but
i should know that and i don't
yeah i just dawned on me i'm thinking if
i could get eric bienemy and i thought
he
was going to be a head coach and i'm the
jets
then why wouldn't i go out and do that i
take him away from kansas city
and then i have my replacement i don't
have to wait for him to be on the open
market
so i was just wondering if if you were
even allowed to do that
yeah i kind of don't think you are i
mean
i'm trying to think of other sports
and you know i i can't imagine
in the middle of a season that
the tampa bay rays can hire the
the chicago white sox third base coach
i don't know yeah i i don't i don't
think they can but it's a good question
for me to ask
get some of your best people on that
pete okay yeah and then let's get
facing at least in the conversation here
we do that dan you know what yeah quite
honestly
i'm telling you what you should do is
you should have david baker on your show
and you should ask them the question
that you asked me
uh what are the what are the rules about
this
and how if my listeners want to campaign
for this
okay can we do it yeah i think you ought
to do it because
that's the kind of stuff the pro
football hall of fame loves
you know interest in the hall and
interest
in the game so they'd listen to you all
right
uh great to talk to you pete thanks dan
good talking to you too that's peter
king who did not yell at me today
todd nbcsports.com football night in
america and of course football morning
in america as well